THE HOUSE.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT
TO HIM.
>> YES, IT WILL BE.
JEFF, JESSICA, THANK YOU BOTH.
>>> TOP REPUBLICANS MEANWHILE
ARE SENDING A PRETTY PRICEY
RESCUE SQUAD TO OHIO TO SALVAGE
J.D. VANCE'S SENATE CAMPAIGN.
HE'S POLLING WORSE THAN EXPECTED
AND HIS CONTROVERSIAL COMMENTS
KEEP SURFACING, AS HE'S NOT EVEN
HELPING HIS OWN CAUSE.
HE WAS RIDICULED ONLINE THIS
WEEK AFTER HE SHARED AN IRISH
COFFEE SHOP OWNER'S ELECTRICITY
BILL.
CRITICS WONDERED WHY HE DIDN'T
HIGHLIGHT A BUSINESS IN OHIO
INSTEAD.
AS MANU RAJU REPORTS, THIS WAS
HIS RACE TO LOSE, AND NOW
REPUBLICANS ARE WORKING HARD TO
STOP THAT FROM HAPPENING.
>> Reporter: JUST SIX WEEKS,
OHIO VOTERS WILL CAST THEIR
BALLOTS.
YESTERDAY J.D. VANCE HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT TO FIND.
THE ROOKIE GOP CANDIDATE GOES
DAYS WITHOUT ANY PUBLIC EVENTS.
AND NOW A SUPER PAC IS PLANNING
TO SPEND $28 MILLION ON TV ADS
HERE, ALL TO SAVE A SENATE SEAT
ONCE VIEWED AS A NEAR LOCK.
THE QUESTION EVEN CONSERVATIVES
ARE ASKING --
>> WHERE'S J.D.SOME>> Reporter:
BILL CUNNINGHAM, A RADIO HOST
HERE, SAYS THAT IS A COMMON
QUESTION HERE.
>> HE'S BEEN SPOKEN TO BY AT
LEAST ONE U.S. SENATOR AND ONE
GOVERNOR HE RESPECTS TO KICK HIM
IN THE ASS.
>> GIVEN HOW THIS STATE HAS
TRENDED REPUBLICAN, DO YOU THINK
HE'S TAKING IT FOR GRANT IT?
>> YES.
HE THINKS THE "R" IS GOING TO
PULL HIM OVER THE LINE AND HE'S
PROBABLY RIGHT.
>> Reporter: VANCE IS IN A
COMPETITIVE RACE AGAINST
CONGRESSMAN TIM RYAN, WHO HAS
RAISED SIX TIMES THE MONEY AS
VANCE.
RYAN HAS SPENT EIGHT TIMES THE
MONEY ON TV ADS AS VANCE,
ALLOWING HIM TO BURNISH AN IMAGE
AS A BLUE COLLAR WARRIOR.
>> WHEN OBAMA'S TRADE DEAL
THREATENED JOBS HERE, I VOTED
AGAINST IT.
I DON'T ANSWER TO ANY POLITICAL
PARTY.
>> Reporter: ONE THING HIS ADS
DO NOT EMPHASIZE, HE IS A
DEMOCRAT AND OFTEN VOTES WITH
JOE BIDEN.
>> YOU DON'T ADVERTISE THAT
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT IS.
THAT BECAUSE IT'S A LIABILITY
HERE?
>> WELL, THE DEMOCRATIC BRAND,
AS WE KNOW, AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS FOR A LONG TIME, IS NOT
GOOD IN A LOT OF THESE PLACES.
AND I TELL PEOPLE, LOOK, YOU'RE
AN AMERICAN.
>> Reporter: THE GOP THINKS THE
COMING AD CAMPAIGN WILL LOOM
RYAN.
>> YOU RAN AGAINST NANCY PELOSI
AND THEN VOTED FOR HER.
>> IN THIS ENVIRONMENT, DO YOU
HAVE THE GUTS TO TAKE ON YOUR
OWN PARTY?
AND FROM MY VANTAGE POINT FOR
ME, IT'S A RESOUNDING YES.
>> Reporter: UNLIKE RYAN, VANCE
IS A POLITICAL NEWCOMER.
A BEST SELLING AUTHOR, VENTURE
CAPITALIST, AND FORMER MARINE.
WHO USED TO SAY --
>> IF I'M A NEVER TRUMP GUY.
>> Reporter: YET VANCE WON OVER
DONALD TRUMP FOR HIS
ENDORSEMENT, ENOUGH TO WIN THE
CROWDED GOP PRIMARY IN MAY.
VOTERS STILL SAY THEY'RE WAITING
TO HEAR MORE ABOUT HIM.
>> HAVE YOU SEEN MUCH OF J.D.
VANCE AROUND HERE?
>> NO.
>> Reporter: VANCE DECLINED TO
BE INTERVIEWED.
CNN DID OBTAIN COPIES OF
INVITATIONS TO TWO FUND RISERS.
CNN TRIED TO FIND VANCE AT HIS
CAMPAIGN OFFICE.
AND ATTEMPTED TO CALL HIM ON HIS
CELL PHONE.
BUT SOME VANCE DEFENDERS INSIST
HE HAS HAD A STRONG PRESENCE
ACROSS THE STATE.
>> I SEE J.D. VANCE HERE, I SEE
HIM ACTIVE.
HIS TEAM HAS BEEN REALLY STRONG.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICANS BELIEVE
THAT J.D. VANCE WILL BENEFIT
BECAUSE MIKE DeWINE, THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR, IS EXPECTED
TO WIN IN HIS RACE.
COULD HAVE COAT TAILS LONG
ENOUGH TO HELP VANCE.
AND DEMOCRATIC OUTSIDE GROUPS
ARE NOT PLANNING TO SPEND THE
MONEY MITCH McCONNELL'S GROUP
IS.
REPUBLICANS EXPECT VANCE TO BE
MORE VOCAL IN THE COMING DAYS.
JUST MOMENTS AGO, HE WAS AT A
CLOSED EVENT AT THE CHRCH
BEHIND ME HERE IN COLUMBUS.
WE TRIED TO INTERVIEW HIM AND
PUT A BUNCH OF QUESTIONS TO THE
CAMPAIGN.
THE CAMPAIGN SENT US A STATEMENT
ATTACKING CNN.
>> MANU RAJU, THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORTING FROM COLUMBUS, OHIO.
>>> NOW LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF
THIS WITH NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
PHILLIP BUMP.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, BOTH
OF YOU.
ON THIS REMARKABLE FIGHT THAT IS
PLAYING OUT, THAT'S THE BEST WAY
TO PUT IT, BETWEEN THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN'S CAMPAIGN CHIEF AND
MITCH McCONNELL, THIS IS BETWEEN
RICK SCOTT AND MITCH McCONNELL
OVER A COMMENT THAT McCONNELL
MADE ABOUT THE QUALITY OF THE
CANDIDATES THAT REPUBLICANS
HAVE, PEOPLE LIKE J.D. VANCE AND
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE HAVING TO
PUT ALL THIS MONEY INTO THE
RACES.
RICK SCOTT SAID IN AN OP-ED
TODAY IN THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER, MANY OF THE VERY
PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR LOSING
THE SENATE LAST CYCLE ARE NOW
TRYING TO STOP US FROM WINNING
THE MAJORITY THIS TIME BY TRASH
TALKING OUR REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES.
ULTIMATELY IT IS TREASONOUS TO
THE CONSERVATIVE CAUSE.
HE'S TELLING MITCH McCONNELL TO
PIPE DOWN WITHOUT NAMING HIM.
>> I MEAN, THE SUBTLY IS NOT
SUBTLE AT ALL.
THIS IS A FEUD THAT'S BEEN
PLAYING OUT OVER MONTHS.
YOU HAVE DIFFERENT STRAT JIS HOW
THEY SHOULD GO ABOUT TRYING TO
GET BACK THE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY
IN THE SENATE.
RICK SCOTT HAS STAYED AWAY FROM
THE PARTY PUTTING ITS THUMB ON
THE SCALES IN THE PRIMARY.
YOU CAN'T ANGER THAT MAGA WING
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
MITCH McCONNELL IS RECOGNIZED AS
BEING THE MASTERMIND OF
REPUBLICAN STRATEGY THERE, HAS
HAD A SERIES OF WINS
UNDERSTANDING THE MECHANISMS OF
THE SENATE AND PUSHING FOR A
MORE TRADITIONAL SENATE
CANDIDATE, SOMEONE BETTER
POSITIONED TO WIN OVER
INDEPENDENTS AND MODERATES.
BUT NOW YOU HAVE CRITICISM OF
SCOTT FOR HOW HE'S MANAGED THE
MONEY, ABOUT MAYBE THAT THESE
SENATE CANDIDATES AREN'T WHERE
VOTERS ARE.
AND THE POLLING IS NOW BACKING
THE McCONNELL POINT OF VIEW.
YOU HAVE HAD CANDIDATES LIKE
HERSCHEL WALKER IN GEORGIA, DR.
OZ IN PENNSYLVANIA, WHO HAVE
BEEN FALLING BEHIND BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO KEEP UP
WITH THE ENERGY OF THE PARTY.
AS ISSUES HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM
REPUBLICANS AND HAVE FOCUSED
MORE ON DEMOCRATIC AGENDA, THOSE
SENATE CANDIDATES HAVE STRUGGLED
AND THE CRITICISM OF SENATOR
SCOTT HAS RAMPED UP, TOO.
>> OF COURSE, WITH THESE
CANDIDATES, WHAT THEY HAVE IN
COMMON, THEY'RE ALL POLITICAL
NOVICES.
THEY GOT THESE TRUMP
ENDORSEMENTS, WHICH HELPED THEM
IN THEIR PRIMARIES.
BUT THE QUESTION THEN BETWEEN
McCONNELL AND RICK SCOTT, IT'S
NOT TRANSLATING TO VOTES.
>> THIS IS THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, HOW MUCH DO YOU RELY ON
TURNING OUT YOUR BASE, AND HOW
MUCH DO YOU NEED TO APPEAL TO
THE CROSSOVER VOTE SNERS DONALD
TRUMP'S STRATEGY FROM 2016 AND
2020, TURN OUT THE BASE,
ENERGIZE THE BASE, GET THE BASE
TO COME ALONG.
IT WORKED FOR DONALD TRUMP IN
2016.
NOT IN 2020, OBVIOUSLY.
BUT THIS IS THE STRATEGY THAT
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS DOING.
LINDSEY GRAHAM WAS ASKED GIVE US
YOUR PITCH ON HER SHELL WALKER.
HE SAID LOOK, HE'S GOING TO WIN.
YOU HEARD THE RADIO COMMENTATOR
SAY HE'S GOING TO RELY ON THAT R
NEXT TO HIS NAME.
VANCE AND MASTERS IN ARIZONA
BOTH WON BECAUSE THEY GOT ALL
THIS OUTSIDE MONEY FROM THIS
GUY, AND NOW IT'S A FIGHT
BETWEEN McCONNELL AND TEAL ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TEAL WILL COME
IN, IN THE GENERAL.
SO THERE'S ALWAYS THESE LAYERS
AT PLAY, BUT IT COMES DOWN TO
HOW ARE REPUBLICANS GOING TO
WIN?
>> AND THEY'RE STRUGGLING MORE
THAN THEY THOUGHT.
ANOTHER TRUMP BACKED CANDIDATE,
SARAH PALIN, LOST HER RACE LAST
NIGHT.
THERE HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS --
IT'S ALASKA, SO THERE ARE
QUESTIONS WHETHER YOU CAN READ
TOO MUCH INTO THAT AND WHAT IT
FORESHADOWS FOR REPUBLICANS THIS
NOVEMBER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YEAH, IT BUILDS ON THE LARGER
TRENDS.
IT'S NOT JUST THAT PALIN RACE IN
ISOLATION, IT IS A REPEATED
EXAMPLE.
YOU HAVE THE SPECIAL ELECTION
RACE IN NEW YORK.
YOU HAVE INDIVIDUAL REFERENDUMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHERE
DEMOCRATIC ENTHUSIASM HAS RISEN.
THAT'S PROBABLY UNIVERSALLY
RECOGNIZED.
YOU HAVE SEEN THE BACKLASH AFTER
THE DOBBS DECISION FUEL
DEMOCRATS.
AND YOU'RE SEEING WEAK
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES NOT
GETTING THE TRUMP BOOST.
TRUMP STRATEGY'S CAN WORK
BECAUSE HE FINDS A VOTER THAT
WILL COME OUT FOR HIM.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT THAT SAME
TYPE OF VOTER WILL COME OUT FOR
A SARAH PALIN, WILL COME OUT FOR
A BLAKE MASTERS OR A J.D. VANCE
IN OHIO.
THEY ARE HOPING THAT THIS RACE
BECOMES NATIONALIZED, THAT THESE
INDIVIDUAL RACES BECOME WRAPPED
UP IN THE LARGER D VERSUS R
BATTLE OF POLARIZATION.
IN ALASKA, IT BUILD